معنا الان من شمالي غزه الصحفي عماد زقوط
سيد عماد ارحب بك مراسل الجزيره كان قد
تحدث اذا عن ان قوات الاحتلال دهست خيام
النازحين بالجرافات في ساحه مستشفى كمال
عدوان وقتلت من فيها كيف تتابع هذا
الامر نعم اليوم ذهبنا الى مستشفى كمال
عدوان بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من
المستشفى من محيط هذا المستشفى
وجدنا
ودمارا قوات الاحتلال ارتكبت في هذا
المستشفى اربعه جرائم الجريمه الا وهي
حصار مستشفى كمال عدوان لمده ما يقرب من
10 ايام منعت عنه الماء والطعام والدواء
ومنعت من تحرك سيارات الاسعاف وحاصرت اكثر
من 3000 مواطن نزحوا الى هذا المستشفى
وكذلك عدد كبير من الجرحى والاطقم الطبيه
التتي كانت متواجده في مستشفى كمال
العدوان وايضا هنالك اكثر من 20 جثه شهيد
كانت ايضا موجوده في مستشفى كمال عدوان
الجريمه الثانيه وهي اقتح حام هذا
المستشفى وتدمير سور المستشفى وتدمير
مقتنيات
ومرافق مستشفى كمال عدوان وايضا الجريمه
الثالثه وهي
جريمه التنكيل بالمرضى والتنكيل بالجرحى
والتحقيق مع النازحين واعتقال عدد من
هؤلاء النازحين واعتقال عدد من الاطقم
الطبيه ومدير مستشفى كمال عدوان الجريمه
الرابعه وهي حسب شهاده الدكتور محمد ظاهر
وهو الذي يعمل في هذه المستشفى وهو
عدد من الجرحى والمرضى وهم احياء في داخل
ساحات مستشفى كمال عدوان راينا الكثير من
الدمار والخراب في هذا المستشفى وكانه سكن
عسكريه هذا المستشفى المدني هذا المستشفى
الذي يقدم الخدمات للجرحى والمرضى على
مدار ايام
الحرب الجاريه وراينا الكثير من التدمير
في هذا المستشفى ومحيط مستشفى كم العدوان
ايضا المرافق العامه الشوارع الم باني
المساكن جميعها تم تدميرها بشكل كبير
والاضرار التي لحقت بهذه الاماكن كانت
اضرار كبيره جدا في ما يحيط مستشفى كم
العدوان هنالك حسب شهادات الممرضين و
والاطباء في داخل المستشفى كدون الذين
كانوا محاصرين مع هؤلاء المرضى والجرحى
والنازحين داخل المستشفى كمال العدوان
تحدثوا عن الكثير من الالام الكثير من
حالات تنكيل بهم داخل اسوار مستشفى كم
العدوان بسبب هؤلاء بسبب جنود الاحتلال
كان هنكد من الجرحى عدد من المرضى توفوا
واستشهدوا بسبب النقص الحاد في الماء وفي
الطعام و الدواء بسبب الحصار الشديد الذي
كان م فروض على مستشفى الوان لاكثر من
ايام وتواجد الاليات العسكريه في محيط هذا
المستشفى تهديد بقتل كل من يتحرك داخل
المستشفى
تحدثوا عن اليه الاعتقال والتمكين
بالنازحين كيف اعتقلوا الشبان كيف نكلوا
بالنساء كيف نكلوا بالاطوال كيف منعوهم من
التحرك كيف تنقلوا من مكان الى مكان داخل
مستشفى كمال العدوان بسبب النيران الكثيفه
التي كانت توجه الى مستشفى كم العدوان
وجدت قسم الاطفال وقد دمر بالكامل وجدت
الكثير من المرافق داخل المستشفى رت
بالكامل هذا الخراب الذي اراده الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بحق مستشفى كمال عدوان وهو
المستشفى المتخصص بالنساء وبالاطلاع
والالاف من المرضى في شمال قطع غزه من
النساء ومن الاطفال الان حرموا من تلقي
العلاج والخدمات الطبيه والصحيه في هذا
المستشفى بفعل هذه الاله العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي دمرت وخربت مستشف من
العدوان الذي كان يخدم هو الوحيد في
الايام الاخيره من الحرب الذي كان يخدم
منطقه الشمال وايضا مدينه غزه لكن الان لا
يوجد اي من المستشفيات في شمال قطع غزه
جميع هذه المستشفيات قد تم تدميره مستشفى
الاندونيسي الذي تم محاصرته وتم اقتحام
هذا المستشفى وتدمير مرافق هذا المستشفى
كذلك تم تماما بمستشفى كمال عدوان بل كان
الخراب والتدمير اكثر واكثر داخل مستشفى
كمال عدوان ايضا مستشفى العوده الذي تم
محاصرته يطلق النار عليه واصابه عدد من
الاطباء واستشهد عدد من الاطباء داخل
مستشفى العوده هذه حاله التنمير هذا هذه
الاله التدميريه لدى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الذي يريد ان يحرم الاف المواطنين من
الخدمات الصحيه والخدمات الطبيه في شمال
قطاع غزه وهو الهدف الوحيد هو الموت وهو
القتل الجماعي لهؤلاء المواطنين الذين
يريدون ان يبقوا هنا داخل شمال قطع غزه
وفي في مخيم جبال وفي جباليا وفي بلاهي
وفي غيرها من المناطق في شمال قطع غزه
الذين ثبتوا هنا يريد هذا الاحتلال تهجير
هؤلاء وحرمانهم من اي خدمات طبيه وصحيه في
شمال قطع غزه وبل اكثر هو يريد تدم تدمير
كل هذه المرافق وبل دمر تلك المرافق
الصحيه والطبيه وهو الذي يقتل يقتل تم
التنكيل ايضا بجثمان الشهداء راينا ان
جرافات عسكريه اسرائيليه كرك بالشهداء
ايضا راينا مشاهد قاسيه جدا بالشهداء
الذين تحللوا والذين تم تجريف جثمان هؤلاء
الشهداء العش داخل مرافق مستشفى كم
العدوان راينا اهالي وذوي الشهداء الذين
اتوا الى مستشفى كمال عدوان و وارادوا
التعرف من جديد على ابنائهم الشهداء
ونقلهم لدفنهم في مناطق مفتوحه في شمال
سطع غزه لحرمان ايضا هؤلاء المواطنين من
المقابر العامه التي
تم ايضا تواجد الاليات العسكريه الان
اينما تذهب في شمال قطع غزه وفي مخيم جزيه
تجد في الشوارع في السحه العامه في مدارس
الاواء تجد مقابر جماعيه للشهداء بسبب هذا
العقاب الجماعي وهذه التدمير ايضا السيطره
وراينا كيف تم تجريف مقبره الفلوجه وهي
المقبره المركزيه لمخيم جباليه ايضا راينا
الجرافات العسكريه وهي جرفت مئات المقابر
التي تعد اي منذ سنوات هذه المقابر تم
تجريف ايضا في مقبره الفالوجه هذه الاله
التخريبيه والتدمير والارهابيه لدى الاله
العسكريه الصبيه هذا ما نراه نراه هو
تدمير الحاله المدنيه الحاله الانسانيه في
هذه المناطق في مناطق شمال فطع ام